you two are adults but you cast the
other kids are kids the other kids in
the show are our age just the kids that
are there they look like they're 12 13
they're real kids yeah and you know I
when I was when we were talking bout
this backstage before the show there
were shows like Beverly Hills 90210 that
would want to portray teenage years and
they would go out and hire 40 year old
people do it you you've surrounded
yourself with kids that are really this
age what is it like working with 12 and
13 year olds there's a lot of I mean
generally great generally that you know
but as kids got more comfortable to like
improv you never knew what was gonna
gonna happen yeah yeah this one actor
who's really good he was just really
inhabiting the role we were like making
fun of each other back and forth and
mine was nonsensical I was like well
you're an idiot guy and then he was like
well you got a big-ass nose and I was
like uh yeah and you gotta try to just
he took the wind out of you know it's
funny he puts you right back at being
that age where he talked about something
on your face and made you totally self
told me that my I like when in his face
and he was like oh your breath is nasty
and I was like that's real
[Laughter]